congrats
on the series and also um a fan of your
work behind the camera so
nice to talk to you today nice to talk
to you too
uh i want to start with um and i want to
read this to make sure i get it right
um how did your work as a documentary
crew member on pop star
and kwaki in mcgruber help you prepare
for the role of the queen's gambit
that's funny yorman just asked me if i
had spoken to you yet today
you know the thing is is every role
plays a part in the greater puzzle of
how you come to a role
and my small insignificant parts in my
husband's movies have really taught me a
lot about
how to take on alma wheatley
oh i've been everyone i've been talking
to recently i've been asking the same
two questions i want to
do this for you um what tv show would
you love to guest
write and direct i'm re-watching the
west wing right now
probably from a place of
you know just wishing that that was more
like our world
um that would have been a fun one
i think like old shows i look back at
like shows like taxi or
like cheers and think like man i wish i
could go back and
just direct an episode of one of those
shows that i loved and grew up loving
what movie do you think you've seen the
most either waiting for guffman
or the room um
you know i was a theater nerd and so
waiting for guffman was like our
our movie we watched it at every party
it was sort of like
in theater school it was just on in the
background every day
because we felt very seen by that movie
all christopher guest movies but
particularly waiting for goffman i grew
up doing community
theater in a small town here in the bay
area and so that movie
really made me feel seen jumping into
why i get to talk to you today
um i'm a big fan of scott frank and i'm
curious as
uh this was your first time acting in a
while i believe 10 years yeah
so what was it like stepping on set
because you have a really big part
uh but you're also been directing a lot
recently so
how does that sort of did that play any
havoc with your mind
when you're standing on set acting and
you're like oh
would i change that lens scott and i are
our buddies we've been friends
we met through the sundance labs and
when i was making my first movie the
diary of a teenage girl and so i have
visited
him on sets before and he's watched cuts
of my movies i've watched cuts of his
things we really have a
relationship director to director much
more than director to actor
um and so it was a very weird
shift for me to show up on set and to be
in actor mode and i really tried to put
my director hat
aside and say you know i'm here to do
one job and for me
it was glorious it was like i
got to as a director you have to think
about everything you are thinking about
not only how the scene is going to play
out how the acting is going to go what
lenses you're going to use how you're
going to shoot it but also the clouds
and are they going to move and are we
gonna make lunch
and what about tomorrow and do i need to
rewrite that scene and
you have more things on your plate than
i can possibly explain and as an actor
you get to come in and be
incredibly focused on one thing and you
have to do that well but you have to do
one thing and so for me it was great
because scott would say like
okay so i know this scene looks weird
we're gonna do this in vfx and i'd go
scott
not my problem i don't care i'm not
thinking about that i don't have to go
to your vfx meeting i don't have to look
at those proofs i'm good like it made me
i felt this lightness where i didn't
have the weight of
that responsibility on my shoulders but
he and steven meisner the
dp would tease me all the time i would
come in and they'd go so how would you
film this
oh well i guess mari could have shot
this better you know it was there was a
constant
or they'd look at me and go what do you
want to say give us the note
i would be like no i'm not backseat
directing i swear
that's great uh one of the things that i
really responded to
about the series is the fact that
there's no villain that
the mom is not some evil person that the
the other chess players are not out to
get her or steal
i mean it's just it's refreshing and the
villain is is anya trying to overcome
herself
yeah she's she's got her own struggles
with her own mind that she has to
overcome
and it's really in that way that's why
it is such a coming-of-age story and
it's about her relationship with herself
and what it is to be a woman i think too
you know part of what i loved about my
character being such a complex
not villain but not a perfect mother
figure in any way
and also you know beth's real biological
mother both of us are these sort of like
cautionary tales of who you don't want
to be i'm this alcoholic
mother who never got to fulfill her
dreams who's been locked in a loveless
marriage and then she has
her biological mother who pretty much
went crazy
and you just think like these are her
examples of womanhood these are who she
could become and she has to forge her
own path
and find a way to really be herself
and it takes her a long time but she
gets there you guys got to film in
berlin
and right yeah uh one of the things
about the series is like
the incredible production design and
it's just there's like as i've been
saying in other interviews but there's
like no weak
link in this chain from the
cinematography to the production design
to
everything i mean the sh i can't believe
it's not all we're talking about is just
how beautifully the show is shot
and how beautifully it's designed it's i
could just talk about that all day
um berlin was an incredible place for
locations but the production designer
just did an incredible julie just did
such a beautiful job as well
i mean you are transported back in time
and
we were able to film scenes
that were russia and mexico city and
vegas all in berlin
and it really just put all of us i mean
i recognize because i'm a director how
much work goes into the moment that an
actor arrives on
set and goes well look at this this is
cool and it's like oh it's taken a year
of work
to get to that moment where we get to
film that scene and for me it was like
a present every day because i would just
get to show up and be like cool where
are we going today and show up to these
beautifully decked
even scenes like going shopping in a
department store
like a 1950s department store and it was
just
the lushness of the design was so
beautiful it was wonderful
as i was watching it i was just you know
uh when you get to be transported like
that it's just uh
it adds so much and i think right now in
this moment in time this show is a
really fun
escape for that reason we're all locked
in our houses and to actually get to
just
watch this beautiful i mean it's such a
compelling story but it's also just a
beautifully shot and designed
show i know you have what the
constitution means to me which is coming
up for you
uh but i'm curious if there's any other
directing
projects uh that are coming up for you
besides that one
um i have a project called five women
that i've been developing but that we're
not gonna be able to film until the
world opens back
up you know we were really lucky with
what the constitution means to me that
we finished filming i think
a week before the shutdown happened and
um
so and projects like queen's gambit had
that
happen as well where we were done
filming and you can really do a lot of
post
editing and sound work during this
quarantine but it's a lot harder to
shoot
and i have a newborn so i'm not going
into production anytime soon but when i
do five women i'll be the first thing
that i do
got it on that note i need to stop i'm
just to say congrats on this project and
everything else
and uh and you know i'm sure i'll talk
to dormant soon
um yeah later have a good day great to
talk to you bye